what's up
he's just you know kind of looking side
to side but uh not really doing anything
if you know those bad guys out there and
you know they're shooting going on the
first thing you're going to do is at
least just change direction hi Matt
Zeeman I'm an instructor at the Air
Force's area University at Maxwell Air
Force Base I've been a pilot for 26
years today we'll be looking at World
War II dogfight scenes from movies to
determine how real they are
[Music]
we actually did get a couple of
airplanes airborne and uh I mean those
are all Amazing Stories the guys that
are Loosely depicted in this scene Welch
and Taylor they were out partying the
night before all night poker game and
they had just gone to bed like about an
hour beforehand they heard the bombs
going off they were still wearing tuxedo
pants they jumped in a car going about
100 miles an hour getting shot at along
the way true story
so if you've got a plane chasing another
one in level flight those bullets are
going to be shooting out way ahead
they're not going to be splashing down
on the water right in front of it
competition aerobatic planes and you
know modern Fighters can kind of do a
knife edge pass like that but uh you
know a P40 couldn't do that if you're on
its side flying through a basically a
canyon of buildings like that uh you're
you're gonna end up flying into the
buildings the Japanese did fly extremely
low so uh I guess there's some realism
there but there were multiple accounts
of guys seeing planes that were either
scraping the belly fuel tank or uh uh
you know scraping the the tips of their
propellers Welch and Taylor and the
other guys that actually did get in
dogfights were up at higher altitudes
not flying at Treetop level
oh
[Music]
come on so mid-airs do happen in air
combat when you got a lot of planes
flying around the sky but to have that
kind of coordination you know do a
head-on pass and and you know cut right
at the last second so that the the zeros
would fly into each other is uh quite a
bit of fiction
[Music]
um so that's one thing that I think
Hollywood uh pretty often gets wrong in
showing uh just this unlimited Firepower
it's limited to begin with which is why
you fire short bursts you don't waste
your ammunition or Welch and Taylor
didn't even have a full load of their
guns when they got airborne
[Music]
he looks like a kid in an arcade game
with both hands on the stick you know
going left and right you don't do that
uh your left hand's on the throttle the
only time you really use both hands on
the stick is you know if you're pulling
back in kind of a brake turn I give it
about a four
enemy Fighters
using a hand microphone like that if
you're not wearing an oxygen mask that
has a microphone in it uh guys will wear
throat mics that uh it would kind of
pick up the vibrations in your vocal
cords and if you think about it you fly
an airplane with your right hand you're
definitely not uh gonna have time in the
middle of combat to pick up a microphone
and talk into it and put it back and
then take control of the airplane that's
uh completely unrealistic
oh
we call that a snapshot you know it's
just kind of a quick Target of
opportunity as bad guys pass in front of
you the SBD dauntless it's a scout dive
bomber but actually did pretty good air
to air it had a about a three to one
kill ratio so it actually shot down
three enemy airplanes for every uh
dauntless that got shot down by an enemy
airplane
so there's two kinds of enemy fire
against aircraft there's barrage fire
which are Flack which are shells that
explode at kind of a predetermined
altitude and then there's kind of the
aim fire you know typical machine gun
the Flack is those black bursts that are
happening and those bursts are falling
all the way down the die that's not
terribly realistic you know that would
be kind of blanketing a certain altitude
and then you would have the machine gun
fire that would be you know tracking the
guy through the dive
he's releasing later than they they
really would so you would roll into that
near vertical dive and and uh typically
release the bomb at about 2000 feet to
recover around 500 feet the reason they
do dive bombing is because if you're in
a level dive and you you know drop a
drop a bomb there's a lot of error that
can happen the steeper your dive is the
more you're basically just dropping
straight down it minimizes a lot of
those those errors because they're in
that vertical dive you don't want that
bomb to be going right through your
propeller Arc and hit your blade so they
had a little trapeze when you would
release the bomb it would swing the bomb
outside of the the diameter of the
propeller Arc uh to to be clear of the
aircraft he does a decent job of kind of
showing the g-forces as you pull out
from a dive you're pulling pretty
aggressively there
foreign
that is a fairly valid tactic you can't
really see in the cloud so uh disappear
into the cloud may fly around a little
bit pop out a different side and hope
that the bad guy doesn't find you and
saying for the zero to just be right at
that point in time as he comes out of
the cloud to be right in a shooting
position
a little unrealistic
the idea to you know kind of haul back
with both hands is pretty accurate some
guys would even black out call it g-lock
g-induced loss subconscious but the idea
was hey if if I'm still holding back on
the stick the nose is is going up so I'm
at least you know flying away from the
ground and you know even if I pass out
or release the stick the blood flow will
start coming back and and I'll wake up
but uh but yeah that defies the laws of
physics you know to to release it you
know about 200 feet there and and
recover just skimming the deck of the
carrier
all right
[Applause]
that guy out in the water that's a Anson
George gay he was the only guy to
survive from his Squadron the entire
Squadron got shot down but he watched
the entire Battle of Midway bobbin in
the water there uh and was eventually
rescued but uh quite a quite a witness
to history
so he's jinking there which are you know
doing kind of rapid changes in Direction
so the Gunners can't track you easiest
way to get killed is just fly in a
straight line and be a predictable
Target but you would not fly straight at
an enemy ship like that and fly right at
the guns I'd give this about a three and
a half
very accurate the the Brits operate in a
what they call a three ship Vic uh at
least early in the war and the idea was
the two guys on the wings just follow
the leader and you know he focuses on
the target once they engage then
everybody you know can start firing for
this time period that's extremely
accurate if anything that might be a
little bit wider so they're not uh just
you know close formation the whole time
fuel for this one and two
very accurate for lead to ask for a fuel
check the wingmen uh burn more gas than
lead does so leads making sure that
they've got enough gas and the Spitfire
didn't hold a lot uh just a little bit
over an hour of flight time so to take
off from an Airfield and in southeast
England and get over to the French Coast
uh you didn't have a whole lot of play
time before you'd have to have to come
back so very accurate consideration
there
even feel shall come out of the sun
that's still a valid tactic today where
you know try to get the sun behind you
because it's really difficult to see
from World War one until now that is
still uh you know a a dominant tactic to
try and you know come out of the Sun the
only downside out of this one is uh
you're not terribly effective patrolling
down at you know wavetop level below 500
feet normally these guys are going to be
up uh quite a bit higher you know 10 000
feet maybe even higher
Spitfire doesn't carry a whole lot of
ammo you're pretty limited so you want
to do short bursts of about two seconds
or so so he's doing a good job there
he's missing the target though because
he's not leading it to hit a point in
space you've got to shoot out ahead of
it so that you know the bullets and the
target meet at the same point in time
bad guys don't always just explode into
a ball of flames it's pretty common you
know if you damage the engine or the
flight controls it'll just kind of be a
gradual descent as opposed to you know
the airplane just exploding or a wing
coming off
thank you
so cool shot a little unrealistic you
know our uh our our fearless Spitfire
pilot has run out of gas which is not
inaccurate for the amount of fuel the
Spitfire carried and you know if you're
engaged in combat over the coast planes
do glide you know once the engine is out
uh Spitfire can go about two miles for
every uh thousand feet of altitude and
I'd say he's at about a thousand feet so
he can maybe go two miles so at that
altitude he's got probably less than a
minute
that's a Stuka dive bomber and the stuke
actually have Sirens installed on them
they were air air powered that makes
that very distinctive sound and they use
that for psychological purposes but it's
funny how you know any movie will show
just about any kind of airplane that's
in a dive will be making that screaming
sound
foreign
to turn around and engage a fighter
you're bleeding energy any turns that
you make and you're you're just you're
going down quicker so the ability to
turn back shoot a guy and then turn back
down the beach it's a little bit of a
stretch I mean the guns work regardless
so uh so theoretically yes it is
possible to uh to shoot a guy down you
know with the engine off
um famous fighter pilot Robin oils got a
kill in World War II he uh he forgot to
switch fuel tanks and right when he was
lined up on a bad guy and and uh so the
engine quit but he was in a shooting
position he took the shot he he uh he
shot down the bad guy and then switched
his fuel tanks and and was back in
business
you'd want to torch the plane so it
doesn't fall on enemy hands the Spitfire
was you know Britain's most advanced
fighter at the time and you never want
to let that technology fall into enemy
hand so they can you know either reverse
engineered or figure out how to negate
the spitfire's advantages so definitely
uh that was pretty realistic to torch
the plane we still do that these days it
just looks like the propellers on a
stick mounted to the rest of the plane
it ignores this entire you know V12
metal engine block that would be uh
filling up that space so you were so
close yeah I'd say overall I'd probably
give Dunkirk about a 7.5 there's a lot
that's really good love the fact that
they use real airplanes
[Music]
we go lightning right behind Red Tails
talks about the Tuskegee Airmen it was a
all-african-american uh Fighter Group
Amazing Story they train right here in
Alabama and due to segregation at the
time they they had to fight really two
battles there was the battle against the
Germans and there was the battle against
segregation and and racism
so the fact that the guys fly in
straight and level he knows there's
Fighters out there and he's just you
know kind of looking side to side but uh
not really doing anything you're just a
Sitting Duck the easiest way to be a
Target is fly in a straight line so if
you know those bad guys out there and
you know they're shooting going on the
first thing you're going to do is at
least just change direction so you're
not a predictable Target
low
[Applause]
planes don't do kind of little hockey
stops like that uh rolling in behind
somebody
the Mustangs are keeping up with the the
Jets which is completely unrealistic
let's get some altitude
[Music]
gaining altitude to be able to get uh
you know more of a energy differential
was was pretty common but you wouldn't
do it uh just by doing a loop right
there you're you're trading in that uh
kinetic energy for that potential energy
so ideally if you see the enemy from a
distance you're able to maneuver and
start kind of a gentle climb so you get
up above them I'd give Red Tails a three
the only redeeming value is telling the
story of the Red Tails which is a is an
important story to tell
so the Bombardier is actually flying the
airplane on the bomb run when he's got
control with the uh with the gun sight
the corrections the the gun sites
basically you know flying the plane on
autopilot and so no matter what the the
Bombardier is doing that will actually
you know Steer the aircraft and uh the
bombardier's got control on the bomb run
oh zero inbound 10 o'clock level going
to call zero ten o'clock that was uh you
know accurate clock position sometimes
in movies they'll they'll call a clock
position you know like enemy Fighters
three o'clock and they're looking to the
left side but three o'clock is off to
your right
so head-on attacks were not uncommon
they would actually fly kind of in a
wall inverted uh to get as close to the
bomber as possible and then you know use
gravity to your advantage so you could
you know pull back on the stick and just
dive away and the Japanese did that as
well because they knew that the the
front side of the bomber was the the
least defended
so there you see kind of the
catastrophic hit sometimes it's it's
just a matter of uh you know hitting a
fuel tank on the wing or hitting the
engine or maybe even just killing the
pilot uh where you don't necessarily get
that pretty big Fireball overall this is
a a pretty accurate clip I'd say they do
a pretty good job with this I'd probably
give it a a nine
you see the brass shell casings coming
out of the Wings that's pretty realistic
a lot of people don't think they just
think about the bullet coming out of the
barrel but not all the brass that's uh
that's uh getting expelled
ramming the plane that did happen if you
have a mid-air collision at those speeds
that force uh it's just gonna it's just
gonna be a cloud of of pieces and parts
in that clip the zero you know looks
relatively unscathed that's complete
fiction
[Music]
if you cut off the tail of the plane the
plane's not going to spin out of control
it's just basically going to fall
straight down because the tail gives it
its stability in Pitch
a few too many airplanes for a Navy
Fighter Squadron at that time but what
they're doing they're dropping their
external fuel tank so to try and
maximize range you would carry external
fuel tanks that you would jettison once
you make contact with the Enemy because
they gave you extra gas but they're
going to slow you down they're extra
drag and extra weight
pretty unrealistic attack run it's not a
dive bomber you know typically the
kamikazes were coming in at you know a
lower angle for him to pitch up like
that uh call it a pop-up attack at the
top of the Apex you know when you uh
pitch over and dive back down you're
pretty slow right there at the at the
peak when you're pitching over and
extremely vulnerable because you're
you're going so slow usually for the
Kamikaze guys they're going to come in
low and they're going to stay fairly low
or they're going to start off higher and
just have all the extra energy to do
that dive to begin with but not do a
kind of a pop-up and Diving attack
they've got you know a couple very small
attention to detail of the brass shell
casings coming out but everything else
just uh pretty terrible uh give it about
a 1.5
St Paul's Cathedral there and Battle of
Britain you know those highest two dog
fights were leaving contrails that were
just swirling masses over the skies that
were visible by people of London and the
English Countryside it was kind of
unique in in Warfare to to watch these
dog fights going on uh overhead
[Music]
you know take a hit in the engine oil
starts spewing out covering the the
windscreen that is uh that's pretty real
you don't have windshield wipers so
you're just kind of stuck with a black
screen in front of you
[Music]
that's a really good job showing what
it's like bailing out of a World War II
fighter you know you slide the canopy
back unhitch your your harness
[Music]
that guy's got a line twist you can't
plan for that uh but that was a minor
malfunction and he's he's a kind of
bicycle kicking his legs to try and get
a kind of a gyroscopic effect to unwind
the the parachute Riser so that's that's
extremely realistic
one of the greatest things about this
movie was how many airplanes they used
the fact that they use real airplanes uh
it was one of the greatest Parts about
this movie they joked that they were one
of the world's largest Air Forces when
they did this this is one of the best
ones out there I give this a solid nine
go get him little friends that's
accurate the bomber guys called the
fighters Little Friends although the
fact that they have p51s p-51s weren't
in combat in uh at this point in 1943
they came along a lot later
[Music]
the Americans operated in a four ship
formation you still got that Mutual
support you'd be in a flight of four
aircraft with two elements or two
sections each one with a you know a lead
and a supporting wingman so that that's
pretty accurate
[Music]
so this we would call a high aspect
merge where you go head to head and
merge with the Enemy a head-on shot like
that again is a really difficult shot
those Fighters are very small and to try
to hit those targets at those closing
speeds are are pretty difficult but when
they show the merge and the and the
Mustangs kind of go up and engage them
uh that's it's pretty good and they're
in a loose enough formation that they
can you know the wingmen are able to
keep sight of lead but also engage uh
the enemy themselves as opposed to just
just flying tight formation
Fighters aren't really flying that close
uh you have to do that just for you know
cinematography purposes to get both
aircraft in the frame Gunner what's
wrong I'm running out of
and this is where it departs from
reality there is no way that the
co-pilot would leave his seat you know
in combat and go take the place of of a
tail Gunner
[Music]
but the fact that you can't control when
when a plane you know goes out of
control that it might you know fly into
a another aircraft or a bomber like that
stuff like that did happen so again when
you have that many airplanes in uh in
that uh you know relatively small piece
of Sky stuff happens I'd probably give
it about a seven and a half
say my favorite World War II dogfight
movie is probably the Battle of Britain
they're using real airplanes and telling
a pretty accurate story if you enjoyed
this video click the link above for more